in negro town you live long and well
there's no disease no sickle cell no
stupid-ass white folks touching your
hair
or stealing your culture claiming it's
there
using words and rhymes to get through
hard times
yeah come on
[Music]
i came from the streets with nothing in
my pockets no food no picks
[Music]
you could take
[Music]
but everywhere we go we don't forget the
struggle son black woman two jobs two
kids too time to juggle them
yum yum yum
in my mouth i got titties in my mouth i
got two
bitties from a bunch of different cities
baby baby it looks like we're back
together
and it's like nothing had ever
torn us apart
[Applause]
[Music]
gonna have a fresh start
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just get into my car
and
[Music]
let's just walk and take it
[Applause]
[Music]
in crowded places so they'll know
that you're back with me
so tonight i'm gonna hit that
tonight
[Music]
i'm sorry that was an involuntary
reaction
hey i i just got a text from charles
y'all he got on the wrong bus
he's on the other side of town other
side of town but our concert is in an
hour yeah
i know but but he wants us to warm up
and rehearse praise to the lord
charles said that in text okay okay well
if that's what charles said
yeah that's okay we got this we can do
what we can do to do this come
[Music]
five on seven eight we lift up to the
lord
we give praise up to the lord we sing
merrily
up to the lord give thanks up to the
lord
we lift up to the lord we take praise up
to the lord
we sing merrily up to the lord give face
up to the lord
i think you're gonna want your note
you're going higher than your note
pretty sure this is my note in fact i'm
positive this
is my note because this is my note
pretty sure this is my note could have
sworn this was your note
that has never been my note well we
can't have the same note
so one of us is wrong why don't you
worry about your note
i'll take care of my own nose but it's a
really really really bad note
you are not tall i never said that i was
charles
well you acting like you thank you
charles look i know that i'm not charles
you can't say that again well you're
both off your notes and it's messing
with the rest of our notes
speak for yourself naima i'm holding my
notes
i wasn't trying to single you out you
said everyone was off that note
not everything is about you gina
kiss my black ass
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know that i've been waiting
[Applause]
baby how could this feeling be wrong
sometimes the thing that you've been
searching for
has been right there the whole time
so baby i'm here to tell ya i'm waiting
right here just to make you all my
you you're the one i always hope for
it's a feeling i can't hide you
and i always been here baby standing
right here by your side
[Music]
yes been building up inside of me
and i just gotta come out
and tell you what i'm feeling girl tell
you our love is what i'm talking about
what it has known for so long
i finally need to show you my eyes are
wide open that's where you belong
you know i make love to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mind i will open up your door i've been
searching all around for the one i can't
call mine
sometimes the thing you're searching for
has been there the whole time
i want to give you all i got now
[Music]
nothing left to hide you sugar say i'm
telling you
everything i've kept very deep inside
a rubbing up against your big bald head
your big bald handle shed your
[Music]
there's no one else i could be possibly
talking about
cause you are bald and you are here
[Music]
you're a woman i'm a man now you
and you know that's how i like it
and i'm specifically talking about you
because you're a girl and i
am the opposite woman woman woman woman
woman
you are a woman i am a man
you know i like women because
i am a man never liked a man in my life
before
you and i don't like one now
ain't no sorrow it's a place to be if
your skin is brown
i'm talking about negro town
negro town what like atlanta
almost now be quiet while i sing
in negro town you can walk the street
without getting stopped or rashed or
beaten there's always a cab when you
need to get around
and they always stop in negro time
i think i'm getting it it's like a
utopia for black people
yeah but seriously shut the [ __ ] up
you won't get followed when you try to
shop
you can't wear your hoodie and i get
shot white folks to cross the street in
fear
this is amazing i know right
[Music]
this sounds too good to be true it does
doesn't it
but can i finish the song i mean can
i finish i'm sorry i'm sorry
in negro town you live long and well
there's no disease no sickle cell no
stupid-ass white folks touching your
hair
or stealing your culture claiming it's
theirs
hanging out in a groove doesn't make you
a gang
every word that you say ain't considered
slang
no one trying to get in on the latest
trend
by making you their token black friend
is the place where harmony is found
it's
talking about me talking about
[Music]
[Music]
oh